last night do you worry about it yeah
yeah I want to hear it what I don't know
what you're about to say yeah yeah I'm
gonna say it I was gonna say okay so I
was at the Christmas party at the Comedy
Store Christmas party and it's there you
know I give him a hug we talked and then
my friend Willie's girlfriend is William
Foresight's daughter right and I can see
let everyone know really enforce William
Forsythe is one of my favorite actors he
was in raising in Arizona a thousand
movies he was in the rock to the
thousand movies you'll know him if you
google him and William fourth s daughter
is a really talented young actress named
Rebecca and she's also dating Willy
Hunter was a stand-up will he's cute but
I was gonna hit on her so I got right
but then she survived and she goes she
immediately made it you know we just
basically that's William Forsythe
daughter and then he was like oh I love
when we text each other but like we had
to save because it could have been
uncomfortable save who who the girl yeah
the girl like that happens a lot what
happens to us to women all the time
where we're very good at maneuvering out
of situations like that he did it she
survived it but it's like I never seen
women there's some girls out there
they're just like he just wants to be
your friend I'm like are you serious but
it made me realize what you guys have to
go through yeah I think that I've become
very like diplomatic in that sense where
and I hate that I'm diplomatic because I
shouldn't be afraid to hurts a man's ego
if no is know then I should just say hey
I'm not interested but I feel like
saying it like in a certain way where
I'm like hey thank you so much I'm
really flattered I gotta go and I kind
of like as Jojo would say like octopus
yeah yeah yeah what I mean the wiggly
asian man he's good yeah but I wish I
could just say hey dude I'm not
interested bye but it never works out
like that you saw when you picked me up
at that club I pick her up at the club
right and some guy goes he's putting
you [ __ ] no finger to the car to our
window-mounted honor and I said it's so
[ __ ] like he knows I'm picky uh yeah
I don't think that's right no no that's
your uber driver I'm not interested I
gotta go and don't chase me to the car
yeah you know what I did I think I just
have it so growing up in the I grew up
in East LA I went to school in 66 but my
house is located in East LA and like in
that area at least with amongst a lot of
Latinos like they have like this cat
calling thing and it's [ __ ] annoying
like you feel like a piece of meat so I
think at a very young age it's just kind
of like got a really tough skin brush
like [ __ ] you dude and like I think
because of that I've developed like
resting [ __ ] I'm always like like
pissed at something so I don't look very
approachable but do guys I mean because
you're you guys hit on you all that all
the time or still probably yeah um I
don't think I'm in an area now where I'm
never go out anymore so I really get hit
on anymore she gets you talking to hit
on all the time yeah you know yeah but
when I've seen it she people you can see
damn you're really hot then no I think
it's because there's a really big height
discrepancy between him him and I so
they'd always just assume he's my uber
driver or either like or she's an
actress and I'm her assistant dances
like they come out to make email I have
a movie that I'm a coffee bean where the
guy gave the camera to Bobby and he was
like hey dude can you take a picture and
Bobby thought that the guy was asking
him for a selfie oh yeah and so he hands
the camera over to Bobby Bobby flips the
camera like okay like about to take
looking for the guy and then the guy
stands next to me like
okay we're ready like can you take the
picture yeah yeah I guess and then he
takes it yeah
[Music]